[Music]
all right in history solved the news hmm
well actually in mystery solved news Oh
submitted by Joe Melia for all of you
it's called Joe Marley a man Joe Mallya
you don't know it's been years since
we've gotten together he made a video
like [ __ ] like over eight years ago
and shared but like you know it's a
conception of just kidding now and he's
I know you've been traveling a mad salty
when I first met Todd they weren't even
dating now they have kids like it's all
types of stuff you decided to go to
Korea to be a pop star
do you to be [ __ ] famous dude yeah I
don't know when you came back to the
United States United States yep a new
Netflix documentary reveals taped
confessions of Tupac's murder did it
pass the statutes of the limitations so
that's why they could speak freely about
the crimes that they committed
oh damn has it been now no it's actually
because the guy who's who confesses it
he says that he has cancer now and then
he has nothing to lose he just wants the
truth to be out there what if his chemo
treatments actually work and then now
he's okay was he always a suspect or
some random person like I care to Park
no so there's absolutely you are saying
the cops are behind all that too like
those conspiracy stuff 200 that's a
great photo of him what some [ __ ]
dope so that's how he looks like
yeah you don't know the dope ass
eyelashes good we have the same hat size
really when I do a snapback I do two
holes - how do you notice he does
nothing
not even a size of the Hat you choose to
wear it I hated Tupac I put it on the -
I let two holes all the same size how do
you know that's actually how he got his
name - pot because dude that's a little
fun fact for you non wrapped heads out
there yeah that's though II I'm gonna
believe you dude
all right so Tupac was murdered in a
drive-by shooting back in 1996 in Las
Vegas and so one of the suspects known
as ki fede he came out in this
documentary I need to watch this
[ __ ] what is it called
so this Netflix docu-series it's called
unsolved unsolved yeah unsolved alright
um unsolved the Tupac and Biggie murders
it's a ten part Netflix doc I don't care
about because I already know is it out I
need to know about watch it like [ __ ]
tonight but Sookie fede he was in this
other documentary thing apparently we're
like a bt1 it's a documentary star on
death row chronicles yeah to have death
row chronicles are months ago he came
out in this and that's when he revealed
that he's sick and that he wants to just
finally tell the world would happen more
damn I don't believe he's sick unless he
has that - that goes like this
it needs a little compressor tech next
to me was the clothes it's a shift from
Breaking Bad when that guy was in the
ringing Bell guy who was in Jackie
admitted that he killed Tupac no he did
it oh he killed Oh somebody uh he's
being about that every time I'm in Vegas
and I take a taxi from the airport to
any of the hotels on the strip every
single taxicab that I'm in like almost
like in different places like oh that's
where Tupac died not my last case no
Tupac died like next to this like they
always like oh no that's what Tupac died
he died right that's like a day always
they a different place he's a different
play oh my god it's amazing yeah so that
night when he died he was in the car
with Suge Knight
it was like he was driving the car park
was passenger and so now I'm gonna play
the part or he can yeah cool I mean they
call it a confession taxicab confession
key fede and crew go back towards a
strip problem doesn't lose important
lunch meanwhile pocket shoes are driving
for it's 660 foot behind them there are
some girls
[Music]
we pulled up house in the front seat
happens to be my friend Jill she looks
over he sees you he looks right at you
you said the shots came from the back
good Dre Orlando who shot to buck but
then later it came out that he said it
was his nephew orlando no way yeah
orlando baby lame anderson who was the
one who killed puck but orlando died in
1998 so two years later and a shootout
so if you can't really understand like
why changes coming out dislike oh I
forgot to say why so baby Lane
apparently he was trying to steal
something from like one of pucks like
homies and then that's when they ended
up jumping him and so early on there was
that fight in the lobby right yeah I was
at the MGM and they had that video
footage really fight in the lobby yeah
because they were there jumping this
dude and they're all from rival gangs
like Orlando is from South Side Crips
and then Hawk was affiliated with blood
so then that was another added reason
and so that's when he wanted to get his
revenge for being jumped and so they
knew that puck was gonna be performing
at the 662 Club and so that's why they
went to that club he didn't show up they
were leaving so crazy how like just a
senseless killing gets rid of like a
legendary catalog of music and impact on
culture and it was such a big conspiracy
like Suge orchestrated this a lot yeah
or DD or whatever is they have this
whole thing about there's like that new
movie - with Johnny Depp that's like
about thing - right where Johnny Depp
yeah yeah when Forest Whitaker and stuff
I think it was like literally talking
about like the cops were conspiring on
oh yeah yeah it's in the theaters now
actually go see indeed
hashtag so so but in his case like I
mean he could also be paid he just come
out at that time saying that could be
part of the conspiracy too you know yeah
but if this is true then it also does
make sense because it's like yo man they
had a lot of enemies and they just he
was out and about and you're like oh
look it's him
did you look nice silly or was it like a
later died in the hospital later so then
that means that like if this is true
then then Big E big E's death was in
vain then right because supposedly they
were they got back to biggie because
they thought biggie was involved with
the chimp rocks right
well it was a previous Tupac shooting
where he survived and then yeah so I
hate these kind of things cuz like no
one knows ever you know what I'm saying
and then you just have all these people
who don't know [ __ ] throwing out
conspiracy then like it never lets that
person rest you know and I hate that
[ __ ] it's like they just have like a
gangster historian that's just riding
down like a good gangster scribe yeah
[ __ ] [ __ ] and they can fold it nicely
like the asian girl writing a letter and
then put it away somewhere so we need it
well no then you take out a 40 and you
pour it all over it yeah yeah how many
burger what yeah they got it they got a
gangster scroll that's a bandanna print
and then print and then they write it in
Old English nobody gonna hard to read or
the or that cholo cursive mmm-hmm so
they're saying that Suge Knight and
Tupac knew who shot Tupac and then Tupac
himself they do when police were
questioning him cuz he didn't die
immediately that all he said was [ __ ]
you
to the cops cuz they're not rats they're
street i'm riding everyone out oh I
wouldn't they should have told me you're
not gonna survive this one who is it
dude I get shot and grazed on the
shoulder I'm ratting [ __ ] that are you
riding on people you don't even need to
give up yeah and in this book he a
[ __ ] bank robbery and this
[ __ ] oh my god get me out of
this life I didn't ask for this so I'm
has drugs under his beanie right now
I had nothing to do with this crime I
chose the wrong life I wanted it for the
style and the girls man I didn't want
this for the bullets no so now the
documentary the Netflix documentary
producer he's he was calling out to the
cops like hey man like he just confessed
to being an accessory to murder and you
guys aren't doing [ __ ] but then now if
they're coming out saying that the
documentary guys [ __ ] ratting on him
now
that's the tricky thing as no matter
like even if somebody comes out of
confession like now they can't even
prove that he actually did it - yeah you
know me cuz you need more evidence that
somebody just blurting out outlandish
[ __ ] at this point - you know what the
guy already
if he fits a piece man cuz dude say [ __ ]
like that for attention to now you know
what I mean like it's just now you got
to prove that guy did it - that's true
that's like people that say like yeah I
got probed by alien to me - and then
like so the camera crews and they could
be a part of ancient aliens and [ __ ] and
then they can get a spot on History
Channel and then they'll make their own
crop circle in their [ __ ] backyard
and [ __ ] be like they came back what the
thing is literally these mini docs like
the crime mini docs like open up cold
cases again cuz they'd like some of the
journalists did better research than the
cops yeah like that making a murder [ __ ]
one of the craziest things about this
stuff though is how you know you lived
your whole life state like you're this
guy you live your whole life and nobody
knows who you are at the end of your
life and maybe now it's time to juice
some notoriety for yourself because
you're like I wasn't anybody now I want
to be remembered oh yeah being somebody
like this is kind of [ __ ] like like the
kind of not stolen dollar but like
you're trying to like boost yourself you
know by being the gun somebody yeah
being somebody who had significance
whistle blows everyone knows the name
John Wilkes Booth everyone knows the
name Lee Harvey Oswald like that kinda
yeah I don't know something [ __ ] up
about that with our culture it's [ __ ]
up I mean this the mass shooters is that
same scenario
yeah and how I want to see this now you
know saying like like how its applied
the man like I obviously have a desire
to see this because I just said I want
to [ __ ]
tonight and I do but it's [ __ ] up that
I do
that's because humans love gossip and
rumors and all this is is just
next-level gossip at the same time
you're using these people as a moral
compass to you know what I mean like
because you're judging yourself based on
other people and you're like oh if I
idolized this person and they're doing
nothing it's cool that I do that too or
vite or you know or the reverse they're
like damn that should never do that the
clickbait to me is the same [ __ ] right
where it's like it's just supply and
demand like we can all hate on clickbait
all we want but we all have to clicking
on that we all I can't resist twelve
types of new [ __ ] Donuts you never
heard of what or or we need to talk
about this with a thumbnail somebody
won't like this that's okay they need to
talk about with the whole thing and you
got to click from each one to the next
to find out though because you have
something they need to see this in and
it works so it's not like it's bad when
people do that we just know how shitty
it is but we love it but we can't just
like these documentaries whatever is
this I got a scene where he died I want
to see an X on the spot I am one of the
idiots that give that get baited like a
little guppy fish click click click it's
like you wouldn't believe what happened
to dis wife and if she's like on a boat
or something I gotta see this
or even like an article where it's like
it's a it's like why the Golden Girls
were never even friends shooting the
show and I'm like that's such a great
friendship but I thought Blanche and
Gwen were friends or whatever by the way
that show inspired I love that show for
all young uns out the check I go to
girls